hey guys welcome back to the Leia hail
pen show so as you guys have probably
seen across the news over the last few
weeks Andrew Tate has apparently had his
Bitcoin seized by governments so as you
know I talk a lot about Bitcoin I know a
lot about it I've written a book about
it called undressing Bitcoin I'm often
on the news talking about the markets
and where I think the price of Bitcoin
is going I also consult people on
bitcoin and teach them how to take self
custody and also just how to buy it so
in this video I want to do a deep dive
analysis on whether or not it's possible
for governments to seize your Bitcoin so
before I jump into this video and break
it all down don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe so there are two
main ways that Andrew Tay or anyone
could hold their Bitcoin the first way
is by leaving it on a centralized
exchange like a coinbase or binance
where that company has control over the
private keys and if you control the
private Keys you control all the Bitcoin
it's kind of like leaving your money in
the bank the second way which is the the
best way is by taking self-custody which
means putting the Bitcoin inside a
hardware or a software wallet this means
you own and you have access to the
private Keys meaning you control the
Bitcoin and nobody else so there are two
possible options here either Andrew Tate
was in control of his Bitcoin or a
company was in control of Andrew takes
Bitcoin let's say Andrew Tay left his
money on a centralized exchange when he
signs up to this Exchange in order to
use it you have to kyc yourself which
means know your customer so he has to
identify himself he has to give his
passport driver's license and identify
himself with the assets that he's going
to buy so let's say Andrew takes opened
up a cryptocurrency exchange he's got
his name on it and he's living in a
country whereby the government want to
freeze his bank account and we've seen
them do that that same government can
then go to The cryptocurrency Exchange
where he's holding his assets and order
them and instruct them to shut down his
account or just simply freeze his
account now the crypto currency exchange
must do this because they are a
regulated entity operating in a
particular country they have to abide by
the laws of that country otherwise they
get shut down so a very likely option
here is that Andrew Tate left his
cryptocurrency on a centralized exchange
the government then came in and told the
centralized exchange to shut down his
account and they can do this because
like I said he koi seed himself and the
centralized exchange must abide by the
laws of the government and since Andrew
doesn't have the control over the
private keys because he left it on a
centralized exchange they have absolute
control over his assets this is why I
personally never use centralized
exchanges the idea when it comes to
bitcoin and crypto is that you're a
sovereign individual separate from the
state so yes when you have an issue with
the government and you leave your money
on a centralized exchange they have
absolute power and authority to
confiscate your crypto from you in my
opinion that's the most likely situation
that happened here however there are
alternatives scenario so like I said
Andrew may have actually taken
self-custody which means he may have put
his cryptocurrency in either a software
or a hardware wallet a software wallet
is like an app on your phone it can be
like trust wallet or a metamask and it's
basically connected to the internet
which means it's hackable the second way
is by putting your money on a hardware
wallet this is actually the most secure
way to do it because the keys which
control the wallet are completely
offline it's basically like having a
physical device now let's say Andrew
Tate tooks off custody and he had his
Bitcoin on a software wallet which is
just an app on your phone this is easily
confiscatable by governments because if
the government then went to his house
and seized his phone or his laptop they
have access to the app on his phone and
that you can easily Brute Force Through
the app and actually then have access to
their funds so again I personally don't
do that I don't leave my assets on an
app on my phone because it's easily
confiscatable I think he probably left
some money on a centralized exchange
which governments were able to seize but
I also think he likely had some money on
a software wallet on his phone which
governments easily can seize when they
took his phone one really important
difference between leaving your assets
on a centralized exchange versus taking
some self-custody is that with a
centralized exchange you kyc yourself
you identify yourself when you take
self-custody it's completely Anonymous
and so governments won't know which your
Bitcoin is unless of course you have it
on your phone and we all know that
that's your phone because it's right by
your bed so it's definitely possible
that Andrew may have had some of his
cryptocurrency on an exchange which
government seized and also some on his
phone or a laptop which governments were
easily able to seize and then because
Andrew Tate is a very smart individual
I'm pretty sure he probably has some
Bitcoins stored on a hardware wallet now
that's actually the most secure way to
store your Bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency and when your crypto is
on a hardware wallet governments cannot
access it in fact governments will have
no idea that you even own any unless of
course you make it public so my overall
take is that Andrew definitely had some
money left on a cryptocurrency exchange
which governments were able to seize
definitely had some money left on
um some kind of app on his phone and I
definitely think Andrew has some some
cryptocurrency or a hardware wallet
which governments aren't able to seize
because like I said it's completely
Anonymous Andrew would hold the private
Keys he'd hold the seed phrase and so
nobody is able to access that Bitcoin
although I did explain that the main
difference between taking custody and
not taking custody is simply just
identifying yourself there are major
companies which are actually able to
analyze the blockchain and work out
which wallet is whose so say you do take
self-custody and you are in control of
the keys governments can hire experts to
trace all the different wallets and they
can actually trace it back to you this
means that they can then Blacklist and
address which they suspect is yours of
course they don't know 100 but they may
suspect that it's yours they may have
suspected that it's Andrews and so they
can if I Blacklist that address that
means if Andrew was to then send his
Bitcoin from his uh non-custodial wallet
where he takes self-custody and send it
to a centralized exchange they may not
accept his Bitcoin because it's been
blacklisted but why send it to a
centralized exchange anyway when they
can just freeze your account as soon as
the government says but Andrew can still
trade peer-to-peer sending Bitcoin from
one non-custodial wallet to another
non-custodial wallet ultimately the
safest place to store your Bitcoin where
governments can't confiscate it is by
using a hardware wallet where you are in
control of the private Keys a hardware
wallet which I use and I really
recommend is called a tangent I'm going
to leave a link for you in the
description below you can actually get
10 off all it is it's very cool it's
simply just a physical card you get two
cards they're just a copy and paste of
each other and you just connect it to
your phone you tap it and that's how you
sign different transactions it's totally
offline it's safe in your custody and
governments cannot get it we just did a
podcast with sartorial shooter and he
may or may not have revealed whether or
not the government confiscated Andrew
Tate's Bugatti so guys don't forget to
the like button and subscribe as more
will be revealed in the coming weeks